alright guys I'm here with Roy who is
one of the legends of Wall Street
oh he's laughing and rolling his eyes
but but it is true thank you so much for
coming my pleasure thanks for having me
pop absolutely all right so let's go
through your background a little bit
because for those that don't know and
then we can talk about how you got into
crypto sure so so I've been a quant
hedge fund manager for about 25 years
I've started a 93 my own company called
RG neter Hoffer Capital Management and
we've been running a future strategy
that is meant to provide downside
protection and absolute return and
that's been the core of my career all
the way through and in 2017 we launched
a version of that strategy that instead
of sitting on top of the US dollar sits
on top of a core investment in crypto
currencies so we were while that were
fairly new in this fun space my
background in crypto goes back to about
2011 Wow 2011 what um what would it
Ridge '''l II caught your eye about
crypto or how did you discover it and
kind of get interested I actually
remember exactly where I was when I
learned about crypto because it was like
a lightning bolt hit me I was reading an
article on Wired magazine called the
rise and fall of Bitcoin and Bitcoin had
gone from nothing essentially to 22 or
whatever and then down to two or three
and everyone thought it was over a
little bit like today and the the
article talked about the security it
talked about fungibility your coins
aren't in one place they're all over the
world and this thing called the
blockchain
but what really interested me was the
idea that this was a form of money with
a fixed supply
and it that was when the lightning bolt
hit me I said holy cow this is actually
a new technology with the quality of all
new tech that actually seems to make the
tech catch on now in most cases that
that that the thing that the that the
tech has that makes it catch on has to
do with meeting or sex and that's been
true for video it's been true for the
internet we all remember what AOL was
used for at the beginning and it's even
true for things like writing and
speaking you might say that it helps you
find the meet but in this case it wasn't
that it was something else and it was a
problem that has plagued humanity
throughout its history which is how do
you take your stuff from place to place
if you've got a lot of it and in the
case of Bitcoin this was a way to have
your property and not have to worry
about having it be there wherever you
end up far away from where you are now
and used to be having so your diamonds
into the lapels of your clothing or put
your gold in a suitcase and try to carry
it but if you have a lot you can't
really carry it so Bitcoin has as its
real killer app it was asset transfer
mm-hmm
how do you think Bitcoin wealth transfer
transaction kind of all of the elements
of it as an actual currency store value
of exchange type asset plays into more
of the global economy well I think the
the use of Bitcoin is money is very it's
it's very good as a form of money you
can transact in it almost trivially in
fact it's it's almost yeah you have to
be extremely careful when you're
transacting because it is so easy to
transact you can send 10 million dollars
on in a matter of a few minutes and for
almost no money compared to a wire
transfer if you're lucky you can do that
in a couple of days with a bank so as as
a form of international value transfer
it's very effective I'm not sure that
that's the thing that makes it most
interesting to me today
what I've realized over the course of
time is that the the really unique
feature of crypto and in particular the
largest Kryptos is that it's a store of
value with a fixed supply now there are
other forms of that as well but what
makes it unique is that it has layered
on top of it a financial ecosystem you
can make more Bitcoin once you have
Bitcoin just the way you can make more
dollars by investing your dollars by
lending them out to people by buying
stocks and nominated in dollars by
trading alternatives you can do the same
thing with Bitcoin and that is a first
in the history of civilization why is
the fixed supply so important given for
you know decades the Fiat system with
the ability to print more has generally
worked right I think we've been living
in a rather benign time okay I like to
study history and this particular topic
really has led me to conclude that I
don't think there's ever been a 200 year
period where a fiat currency has been
has not been debased
by the issuing authority you can go all
the way back to Roman times there was a
currency called the Denarius which is a
name that sounds unfamiliar but if you
think of the word dinero or the theorem
in in the Emirates these are literally
the same word it was became a synonym
for money the Denarius was like a global
currency back then and when it was a
first issue it was 99 plus percent pure
silver that was around the Year Zero by
250 or so years later it was worth about
0.15 percent silver so even an
asset-backed currency the government
couldn't stop themselves from issuing
too much of it and maybe we can even
attribute the decline and fall of the
Roman Empire to issuing too much
currency but if you go forward you think
about maybe a hundred years ago in 1900
let's say
where would you put your money what
currencies would you've been if you're a
global investor well you would have the
u.s. of course and maybe you had Japan
was a little bit interesting back then
and you probably had Prussia and Russia
and the UK and France and and
austria-hungary in almost every one of
these cases over the next 20 or 30 years
let alone the next hundred and 20 you
had enormous debasement you see what
happens in Venezuela recently where the
only currency is essentially a crypto
currency there was the article in Times
that said everyone has crypto miners
invent in Caracas we saw it in Venezuela
I sorry and I'm Bob ley I remember
paying for lunch and receiving 10
trillion dollars in change for lunch and
so another way to think about it is that
typically when you think about yen or
Turkish lira the old Italian lira all
these currencies started out worth about
the same as a US dollar but most of them
are not anymore and usually if there's a
word new attached there's been ten
million or plus percent inflation so
this has happened over all long periods
of time and I think it's eventually
going to happen in the US why do I think
that I think the US has made promises to
its people that we can't meet here's
about two hundred trillion dollars in
unfunded Social Security Medicare
Medicaid commitments we're gonna have 50
trillion dollars of national debt soon
tax revenues are going to be a hundred
percent devoted to those three things
and service on the debt in about ten
years that's it there's gonna be no
other way to raise money not no other
use for money
because it's all gonna go to that so I
think the only solution even for the
u.s. is going to be to print money and I
see cryptocurrency as a way to take the
take a bet to make an investment in
something that does not have that vice
that over every two hundred year period
in human history has led to currency
debasement
let's talk more about the u.s. issues
right now rigs I don't think people I
think they all here you know with us
radios or whoever saying oh there's
issues there's issues but it actually
don't understand that right what do you
think or the one or two dominoes that
will apply the pressure that could cause
the saram rings I think it's a
probability right and some people think
it's a high probability some think it's
low probability but but it's a nonzero
chance one of those dominoes that kind
of fall first well I don't think it's
necessarily a domino okay I think it's
actually the nature of our system in a
democracy those that are owed benefits
from the government are going to have a
lot of political power so I think the
we've seen it in people that are really
trying to solve the social security
problem we could have done a 20 or 30
years ago but we didn't have the
political will but what I mean by that
is there weren't enough voters who were
willing to say you know I'm gonna take a
small loss now because the next
generation is gonna take it much bigger
loss unless I take my small loss of my
social security of my Medicaid my
Medicare but I don't think it's possible
in a democracy for the people who are oh
these benefits to vote themselves out of
the benefits so we have all either two
options we're either going to default on
these which would mean that government
will be immediately thrown out and
government that makes bigger promises
will be voted in or we're gonna fulfill
those promises but it's going to be in
currency that's worth a lot less so I
think what happens is eventually the
inflation adjustment goes away or become
smaller and somehow those dollars that
we have to that we owe our people are
going to be paid back and they're gonna
be worth less and when that happens that
will be a time when having a fixed
supply form of money is going to be
pretty interesting now one of the things
I like to talk about is well what about
gold we already have some fixed supply
forms of value store I like to tell this
story maybe you heard me say this before
in a conference but right across the
street from where we are now is Grand
Central Station in Grand Central Station
there's a restaurant called the Oyster
Bar which is a remnant of hundreds of
oyster bars that were all around New
York City
every one of these had the same deal was
called the Canal Street plan for five
cents you got all the oysters you could
eat and all the oysters all the beer you
can drink for just a nickel now if you
want to go to the oyster barn cats
that's dangerous right that's a great
deal okay think about maybe four or five
dozen oysters four or five beers four
nickel and now you know if you try to do
that at the at the oyster bar right
across the street maybe you can do that
for 200 bucks so how much is the dollar
devalued in real moister terms right
99.97% or something like that but if you
could have kept your oysters all this
time you still have your same four dozen
oysters and your four or five bottles of
beer sitting there and it's the same
value you didn't grow your money
same thing with gold if you had gold
back then let's say you had an ounce of
gold it's still worth about the same in
as is that as it as it was then
in fact as it was in the year zero you
could buy about one great man suit of
clothing he said outfit a soldier for an
ounce of gold in a suit of armor a suit
of a soldier wear and that's basically
true today what yeah exactly
exactly and that's been true for
thousands of years so even gold it keeps
your value but it doesn't give you more
and you know I kept thinking to myself
why was my oyster story wrong you know
what yes the dollar got devalued by the
federal courts of time but you still
would have done better to have your
money in the stock market and if you
pick the right stock market explain why
that is well the stock market real rate
of return is six seven eight percent a
year above inflation now in nominal
terms it's much higher but the problem
is at the same time the dollar went down
99.97% let's just use easy numbers let's
say the stock market
10% annually right but the currencies
being devalued 2% a year through
inflation right this means net 8 percent
exactly increase in your wealth if
you're inspired exactly so my point is
that if you can have a fixed asset if
you could somehow invest your oysters
and make more oysters if you can invest
your goal that make more gold all you
need is 6 7% and you would have
outperformed the stock market in the
greatest period if stock market growth
in human history now of course you had
to get it right you had to get the US
stock market you might have invested
also in austria-hungary well that didn't
work so well you lost a hundred percent
haven't in France it happened in Germany
I mean where would you've invested your
money that kept its value and it's only
a couple of countries that are
essentially still around that you didn't
lose a hundred percent from from just a
hundred and twenty years we're in a
world that seems very benign right now
but if you look further out and people
managing intergenerational wealth
pension funds institutions endowments
they're looking three four five hundred
years out in the future and it seems to
me that there's a very high probability
that we're gonna see currency debasement
and if I'm right about that any sort of
real rate of return that you can get on
a fixed supply asset is gonna be really
valuable and to me that's what crypto
offers and that's the killer app for
blockchain it's what makes crypto I
believe something that everyone needs to
have in their portfolios what's the
timeline right if you if you and again I
don't think it's a binary it's gonna
happen on this year but
the general we talk in two years five
years twenty years what do you think
this kind of starts to relieve the
average American feels the pressures of
this happening look it might not be for
twenty or forty years okay so you think
it's longer term than two years right
right guy but that's not my that's not
why I'm bullish on does that say Bitcoin
today I think there will eventually be a
growing realization that these problems
were coming down the pike five ten
fifteen years out and in fifty years
they're going to be completely
insurmountable and we're just in dire
trouble
and once that realization occurs then
you're going to see institutions coming
in and putting one two three five
percent of their money just in case this
scenario takes place because they're
gonna be great ways to make money using
crypto there are already ways to get to
three five eight percent by lending it
out there are ways to invent you we have
icos already that that allow you to
essentially invest in equities and what
we do is allow people to invest in
futures in canada and enhancement to
their bitcoin holdings and their crypto
holdings with futures let's talk a
little bit about futures it's actually
think we've done like kind of dot
options 101 etc in previous episodes
but futures is something people have
heard about they shake their head yep I
know exactly that is maybe that no clue
what is a futures contract and how do
they work a futures contract is really
simple it's just an agreement to buy or
sell something in the future instead of
today at some point weeks months years
out who uses a futures contract let's
say you're a farmer and you're growing
soybeans and you know that if you can
sell your soybeans for 13 cents a bushel
then you're gonna have a profitable year
and let's say someone else is a cattle
rancher and they they want to feed their
cattle those same soybeans and they know
that they can make money at 13 cents a
bushel also and have a great year but
the problem is the soybean harvest
isn't now it's next November so what do
you do a futures contract basically says
the farmer will sell those soybeans at
the current price for delivery in
November the rancher is going to buy
those soybeans at the current price and
take delivery in November so basically
it's just a transaction in the future
that you're agreeing to now and we make
that kind of thing all the time we make
we make those kind of agreements in real
life all the time the futures market is
just a place where people can come
together and have very liquid and
readily obtainable counterparties for
this type of transaction got it now that
just just to continue a little bit the
value of one of the of a futures
transaction is that you don't actually
have to sell or buy the whole thing
right now you merely put up a small
amount of capital now and only at the
end do you have to put up the full map
typically in the case of soybeans it
might be one or two percent of the value
one problem with Bitcoin futures which
work exactly the same is that you
put up 40 50 even a hundred or more
percent of the value of your Bitcoin
which means if you're trying to hedge
like if you're a farmer trying to sell
if we're in the case of Bitcoin it would
be if you're a hablar and you're trying
to lock in a current price well for you
you have to put up the whole value of
your position that doesn't really help
you so it hasn't really been a market
that's developed for for crypto futures
but for every other commodity margin
rates are one to five percent and it's
these are enormous markets very often
bigger than the cash markets what's the
general take on Wall Street right now
around
we've talked a bunch about the
institutional world many more like
pensions endowments etc with other fund
managers but what's the take on like
true classic Wall Street I've found that
there is often a generational view that
the younger you are the more likely you
are to see this as a something that is
transformational to see crypto is
transformational I think there tends to
be a political divide I think people
that believe in the goodness and power
of government to make society better
tend to feel that centralized
institutions like central banks do a
better job than decentralized
institutions people that are more
libertarian and believe in the power of
the individual and the importance of
having an individual making their own
decisions tend to appreciate the value
of crypto so I would say that rather
than it being just traditional Wall
Street versus other people that those
are more of the divides that I've seen
now that having been said everyone on
Wall Street is talking about it
recognizes that this might be a thing in
the future there are some people that
are just all in on it and we've seen
Novogratz and people like me that have
just been evangelists for this along
from years and years ago and there are
people that are complete bears and say
you know this technology is not proven
it's too volatile it's too unsafe back
in 2014
there was a drug deal that was
denominated in crypto so therefore I
can't be involved in it at the course
these people are the same people
carrying dollar bills that of which 90%
have traces of cocaine on them which is
true of all dollar bills not just those
they're dollar bills
it seems the generational thing is more
obvious than maybe the political thing
right where you know I joke with people
and I said when we get into these
institutional rooms and we start talking
to folks there's like hey let's close
the door and there's a little bit more
anarchist type view than I think people
would publicly let on and not you know
like let's burn the world
but in a there's probably questions we
should be asking that maybe are or were
previously sacred cows right and and
they weren't popular to ask or they
weren't politically correct to ask but
now like there's some cracks in the
armor and people are saying wait a
minute what about X or Y or Z that's
institutional world though is the same
thing happening on Wall Street or is it
just people benefit from the system and
they love the system because they're the
ones benefiting from it and they you
know are interested in the questions or
even the answers I think inevitably
anytime you have a large business
there's interaction and overlap between
government and business that's just been
the especially in any sort of democracy
where corporations are able to influence
elections by lobbying or other ways or
you have regulators going back and forth
I mean if you imagine the SEC the people
that are Pro crypto and the SEC may have
a job waiting for them at a great crypto
hedge fund in 20 years so there might be
more there might be eventually as there
have been in all other fields the this
back and forth between the regulators
and the authorities will be a very
benign force but for now that force is
to benefit the existing institutions so
I think crypto certainly is a is a
threat to central banking I think if you
know if you're a government
in the Treasury if you're in Central
Bank you have to worry about your
ability to issue money if suddenly
people are able to go into an
alternative to your currency I think one
of the reasons oh and there's some other
reasons technical reasons like imagine
if there were going to be negative
interest rates the way there are many
places around the world right now it's
very hard to prevent people from putting
their money from their bank accounts
instead putting it under their pillow
because instead of losing a percent a
year in your bank you can not lose and
essentially have zero return under your
pillow so why not do that but if there's
no currency there's no cash currency
then there's there's no alternative
crypto represents an alternative to that
and as a result it represents something
that central banks need to think about
if they're considering negative interest
rates and so there's a whole bunch of
issues that are going on right you guys
have been in business for what 25
congratulations thank it's pretty epic
how BIG's the business today and then
how big is the crypto business right
maybe just as a percentage and do you
see that growing quickly is that kind of
plateauing what the general interest
that you're seeing given that we are in
a this is end up November 2018 where
we've just drawn down you know 75
percent or so in in the crypto market so
my business is is mostly non crypto I
haven't had five hundred plus under five
million plus under management and the
crypto fund is just just over about 15
right now and what happens is that we
have positioned ourselves as among the
most downside protective of hedge funds
so our future strategy is becoming very
interesting in a world where we're
seeing central banks reducing the size
of their balance sheet for the first
time in ten years and it may be that
this great burst of liquidity from the
central banks that has floated everyone
stocks and bonds up for the last 10
years with
tremendous declines in volatility seems
to be on it flipped on its head right
now in October we saw stocks and bonds
down and a huge Bristol fall and that
may be caused by the fact that for the
first time central banks are reducing
their balance sheets certainly in the
future we have to consider that the
world of quantitative easing which was
the world of the last ten years may be
going the other way
so what's happened is that the main
strategy has actually gotten a lot more
interesting and of course we're layering
that on top of crypto the problem for
people is that crypto is down 70% it's
it's scary to buy something when it's
down 70% so what we're seeing now are
people that are just thinking about the
asymmetry of the trade this has been my
my core thesis for a long time I could
be really wrong about one out of
everything I've just said now basically
I'm making the claim that at some point
cryptocurrency and I think the largest
Kryptos and perhaps even Bitcoin in
particular are going to achieve reserve
currency like market caps so those are
denominated in the tens of trillions so
if you think about it
the US has to get up to two hundred you
know two hundred trillion is what we owe
our people US money supply right now is
in the tens of trillions so our thought
is well if crypto becomes an alternative
to the US dollar then it also will go up
but say a thousand x from here but I
could be really wrong about that what
are the chances that I'm really wrong if
the chances are you know eighty percent
that I'm wrong you have a 20 percent
chance of making I'd say a hundred to a
thousand x that's an incredibly high
expectation trade in the if you just
think about any bet that you'd make it's
I wouldn't call it a lottery ticket I
think there is a tens of percent chance
and I'm correct about everything I've
said so far and if I am you're in an
investment that's gonna go up more than
any possible investment that you can
make stock market can't go up a hundred
to a thousand times in real value
it might do Ana nominal value if the
dollar depreciates but not on
value but we talk a lot about what other
asset that has 60 billion in market cap
has 50 to 100 X in it over the next ten
years now little ole probability that
happens right in terms of percentages
but high possibility of it occurring
right and I just can't think of another
asset that even comes close right and
said I've been like oh there's another
one is longer do 10x I can't think about
another one that has real possibility of
doing that in ten years right and in
addition to enormous liquidity that you
can buy into today that you can trade on
get out of on a date on a days or even
hours notice that has in addition the
safest blockchain and I mean in case of
Victo and it literally is secured by the
largest computer network in the world
that has been hacked proof for where we
had 10 years now and has this beautiful
antifragility as Talib says the idea
that the more it is tested the stronger
it gets and instead of just being
resistant it actually improves every
time someone tries to impugn it in some
way hacking the blockchain the 51%
attack password problems and denial of
service attacks whatever it is it gets
stronger and stronger and stronger
so those qualities make this a pretty
interesting investment just as a store
of value as is you know where you can
get a few percent in return right now
but you have the possibility as we've
discussed for a hundred to a thousand x
if this larger thesis that i have comes
true
what in the future are you looking
forward to when it comes to Bitcoin and
crypto right it sounds like there's some
crypto specific stuff and there's things
outside of crypto that could be positive
catalyst for crypto itself there's
clearly a move in institutions to as you
say get off zero to get some knowledge
first to study it and then to make some
investments right now it's a few percent
at the high end and half a percent of a
tenth of a percent just people getting
their feet wet but it's coming and it's
been the family offices that we found
that really are the most out front and
that's very typical as as we've seen
with alternative investments we've seen
a my field has managed futures so the
managed futures field it was always the
individuals and the family offices first
then the institution's started to come
in in the late 90s and 20 years on
almost everybody has managed futures I
think that's the way it's going to be a
cryptic so over the long term we do see
that happening that sovereign wealth
funds will probably among the last that
we've actually heard that one is buying
it now so the the entrance Institute of
institutions into the market is a big
deal the growth of liquidity and custody
if you think about where that money is
going to go it's probably not going to
go into coin number 16 and coin number
30 market cap you can't really trade
this it's going to be into Bitcoin and
then maybe from Bitcoin which is like
the u.s. dollar reserve currency of the
crypto space everything is priced in
Bitcoin well maybe people go into the
smaller coins from there so I think
Bitcoin in particular is very
interesting because of its liquidity and
serves as a price of pricing standard
it's important it's it's it's
interesting because of the security of
its blockchain relative to the others
so I think that it is particularly
attractive and so that theme the
concentration of Bitcoin relative to
other currencies I think continues
got it what's the greatest risk in your
mind is it something that's regulatory
is it something that is more it breaks
the story is it an engineering you know
type attack or in a software what
where's that risk come from I think
there are a lot of risks okay and you
and I'm sure you've discussed it before
with many other yes but what why
wouldn't you want to invest in Bitcoin
well number one it's too volatile you
just lost 70 percent from the height now
in fairness it went up a billion percent
but it's down 70 so that's scary
it's illiquid it you can't really put a
billion dollars to work in Bitcoin soon
you will be but right now maybe it's
only a hundred million so if you're
really serious about it like a big
sovereign wealth fund it's not like you
can invest in an yen or euro so it's
it's too liquid there are no derivatives
markets so in my mind that's actually
cause of the volatility the the
derivatives markets that exist have
custody issues a little bit and have
liquidity issues a little bit but again
that's all going to change it's it seems
unsafe it's hard to custody yeah I get
that
we have fidelity already and we have
Gemini we have plenty of people in the
next year they're gonna come in and
solve that problem it's possible there
could be a 51% attack and remember 51%
attacks are you don't just own the
blockchain if you have 51% you're only
going to be able to mess around with
future transactions and to do that
you've got to have much more than 51%
you've gotta have Lex 80% or 90% so
we're talking maybe four times the
largest computer network in the world
and yeah that's possible I suppose but
pretty unlikely you know there's there's
I think I calculated a million computers
mining a Bitcoin and those are all ASIC
computer you know ASIC machines so it'd
be a pretty big effort to do that and it
would be obvious if someone's trying so
I think that's less of a risk and on and
on we can just it is true that in 2012
some people did some nefarious things
using Bitcoin probably without realizing
that
publicly transparent blockchain is the
last place you should be behind drugs
rather than the first place you should
be behind tracks you're much better in
cash than you are on a public blockchain
where one transaction that somebody you
transacted with that could be identified
suddenly brings the trail right back to
you and of course they're catching
everybody now so that turned out to be
pretty silly and you know again the
association with nefarious activity is
the thing of 2010 when people didn't
really understand what was going on
so to me just in general all of these
objections are potentially valid are
interesting objections but they are also
the reason that the price of crypto and
the price of the largest crypt is are as
low as they are the flipside of
everything I've just said and all the
other objections is that therein lies
the opportunity that's why you can get
in at 3,500 and not three point five
million I think this is going it is it's
the classic mark uses an all-timer is
like people will they buy he says they
buy what they should have bought and
they sell what they're about to need
that is the human emotion of this which
is which is pretty crazy to watch play
out you know as as you get deeper and
deeper in this market in you and you see
that it's really retail driven right now
and you know the price really does
reflect that emotional swing absolutely
the people are anchored to 20,000 and
boy does that seem scary that you went
from 20,000 to 3,500 but you also you
went from 20,000 to 3,500 and now it's
on sale if you really believe this story
and again Roy meter Africa could be
completely wrong about this and three
years from now listen to this podcast
and just facepalm and say what the heck
was I thinking to be so bullish on this
or 20 years from now but again there's
it's all probability bit there's I'd say
10 20 30 percent chance that the hundred
to a thousand x story happens
that to me is the most a symmetric trade
I'm gonna see in my lifetime the miracle
is that Bitcoin got from one ten
thousandth of a cent to thirty five
hundred dollars and all this money
pouring into the technology of crypto is
the is going to solve all the problems
and another quick story I like to tell
everyone says well you know there's
there's so much speculation and that's
bad because it creates volatility I
always remind people that the first
speculator and the value of speculation
is some is a story that we all know but
most people don't think of it as a story
about speculation and that's actually
the story of Joseph in the book of
Genesis so Joseph as you may recall got
a great tip that it was gonna be seven
fat years followed by seven lean years
and so what did he do armed with this
tremendous insider information he bought
up all the grain he could find and
stored it just like people used to do
with pork bellies by the way it was the
same trade and in Chicago and he stored
it in greeneries and then he sold it
back out to the market for seven years
and saved the kingdom and became a very
important guy but if you think about it
what happened what was his influence on
the price of grain for seven years he
was buying it up when there was a lot of
grain and then for seven years he was
selling it when the price was high
because it was scarce so he reduced the
volatility of Greene that's what
speculators do it's what's happened in
every other market and the more
derivatives that come out the more
become safer to put your money at these
custody locations and trade derivatives
the less volatile this thing is going to
get and the safer it's going to be as an
investment and the more valuable it's
going to be because of it because you
don't want your store value going up and
down fifty percent absolutely forever
but usually do rapid
questions what do you think is the most
important company in crypto statestreet
stay true because of the custody and
name right when a name-brand custodian
really comes in and figures out how to
do this I love that answer if you could
waive any if you wave a magic wand and
you can change any regulation or improve
one what would it be the taxation of
crypto is so complicated that it creates
an undue regulatory burden most
important book you've ever read Thinking
Fast and Slow by Daniel Kahneman not
about investing but if you read it with
the view of taking every sentence as an
investment tip it'll change your life as
it did mine really ask one non crypto
question and then you get asked me a
question to ended the non crypto
question is just admit that there's
aliens that exist we always think of
aliens as human comparables right you
see in sci-fi movies etc do you think
there's alien animals or alien pets I
think given the enormous number of stars
in the universe every possibility for it
you know there are probably aliens with
pets on pets on pets of pets of pets
that have pets to the infinite you know
you're talking about infinite numbers
essentially so all the possibilities are
for sure and you know I I actually take
pretty seriously this this idea that the
probability that we're living in a
simulation is rather high I haven't
quite come down to it but I think that's
an interesting question so I won't go
too deep into into space aliens well
what I will say though is there is a
higher probability of the simulation
then most people aren't comfortable
identifying let alone admitting to
themselves the part that cracks me up no
matter what you and I think we will
never know that's right it doesn't
matter right and so I said to somebody
one time but if worry if we live in the
simulation that you want to be the
person who won the game
yeah right that's right well I mean it's
like the concept of free will I mean if
we don't have free well it appears that
we do it so why not just pretend that we
do for sure what one question you got
for me what's the most exciting thing on
your mind right now
the most exciting thing on my mind oh I
can't say out loud so
for about a third of my life I have been
intentional about reading writing
learning etc around a whole host of
topics that are all culminating in a
single decision a lot of us around
investing data psychology economics
sociology exactly I said study economics
sociology in college and they are
simplified in some very easy quotes
right now I actually tweeted this
yesterday but I didn't I'll go further
with it so things like by when there's
blood in the streets be greedy when
others are fearful right don't sell the
things that are on sale right those
types of kind of anecdotal statements
mm-hmm
that are very descriptive in simplistic
terms of much much more complex ideas
he's all culminating in this asymmetric
trade around Bitcoin and the last one
that I lumped in with those three year
for quotes was concentration build
wealth and diversification preserves
wealth and so if you can wrap your head
around okay there's a psychological
thing that's happening and then you can
wrap your head around the asymmetry of
the outcome right in the risk/reward
opportunity cetera and you also buy into
concentration builds wealth thought
process you should actually do things
that 99% of other people will think are
too risky
insane etc you have to be comfortable
being wrong and for some of it yourself
or myself possibly being very wrong in
public I think there's that many people
in the world who can understand get to
that point understand the trade of the
financial trade and also the reputation
trade and still pull the trigger
and I'm looking around the room and
you're the global room and I'm saying be
like 10 or less right 20 or less it is
some small number of people who are
going to be able to point back five ten
years from now and say identified it I
understood it I made an intentional
action and here was the outcome positive
or negative and there will be careers
built on this and it will be careers
destroyed on this one it on this one
situation I don't know who it is I don't
know what exactly the impact of it is
but I think it's gonna be really really
interesting to look back in 5-10 years
for now I think that's a great way to
say it I think by the way I think those
people are the most interesting people
in the world who have a long list of
things that I believe that most people
don't believe and you can learn a lot
from them I think having a few or as
many bets like that in a lifetime is a
great way to live one's life and I think
one of the greatest bits of wisdom and
investing is the stock market climbs a
wall of worry and the more you're
worried about the reasons not to invest
in Bitcoin the more that's scary that
the harder it is to pull the trigger the
more it makes your stomach hurt that is
absolutely the time to be long these
things at the time that you are dancing
on the table because you're so clever
that is a time to get the heck out I'll
leave you with one last one
again mark I've learned a lot from said
yesterday he goes anytime you make an
investment and you feel really
comfortable there's a higher probability
you're gonna lose money any time you
make an investment you're sick to your
stomach higher probability you're about
to make money right and I do think that
there's you know there's a hint of truth
in that statement
around the the non consensus right
thought process is usually a really
really good place to be if you can get
comfortable there
yeah which may explain why I have a
stomachache this morning all right thank
you so much this is all I want to do
this again